school is back in session you know what  that means  I'm instead  anything one of us did it what time is  it off campus was his business you read  my post this morning so you guys really  do have some kind of murder clubs what  everyone's calling it on Instagram I  trusted them because they were the only  ones who know what I'm going through  especially  May wake up from this nightmare  I told you nothing to time into any of  this I guess I shouldn't have recorded  all of our conversations then dumbass he  knows we're on to him and he's not going  to hold on to that Xbox forever get the  Xbox out of here okay  [Music]  they want us to believe that during  Jake's Halloween party he just decides  to run away he would have never fled to  Mexico without telling me he said we'd  go back to normal we were not each  other's normal  [Applause]  up